former FBI director James Comey
testified that he met privately with
President Trump on February 14th that's
what he said yeah folks this is good
news for everyone who thought they had
the worst Valentine's Day James Comey
else testified that every time he
thought president Trump was lying he
wrote it down yeah
which explains why Comey was just rushed
to the hospital for carpal tunnel
syndrome this is a part I thought was
interesting today during the televised
hearing Senator Dianne Feinstein told
Comey you're big you're strong yeah then
she said I'll continue the rest of my
statement in the closed session that was
very yeah yeah I made that up today
House Speaker Paul Ryan defended Donald
Trump's behavior saying the president's
new at this Ryan said and by this I mean
following the law
[Applause]
good news Melania Trump Melania Trump is
finally set to move into the White House
next week yeah apparently she's only
moving in because Trump is going to be
moving out so
you're gonna love it
you